madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
effet nous allons développer dans ce
journal le départ du tour de france avec
le prologue au puy-du-fou 180 coureurs
qui ont tous subi les contrôles sanguins
ce matin une première dans l'histoire de
la grande boucle c'est l'américain lance
armstrong qui prend le premier maillot
jaune le chagrin de la vallée du dévoluy
qui rendait un dernier hommage ce matin
à trois de ses victimes la pudeur et le
recueillement
après les déclarations virulentes de
l'ancien préfet bernard bonnet libéré
hier sous contrôle judiciaire
les réactions gorce et puis les départs
sur la route des vacances une journée
classée orange une circulation plus
calme que prévu avec une priorité la
sécurité
l'actualité de ce samedi et sportive
avec le coup d'envoi sous un ciel
couvert de la 86e édition du tour de
france
enfin place au sport en milieu d'après
midi ils étaient 180 coureurs prêts à se
mesurer au départ du prologue au puy du
fou c'est l'américain lance armstrong
qui avait dû arrêter la compétition en
raison d'un cancer qui a endossé le
premier maillot jaune matériel de
rincquesen alain poirier
il ya des signes qui ne trompent pas il
y à des visages qui parle tout seul
difficile éprouvant le prologue du tour
réserve toujours quelques surprises pas
toujours bonne gomez l'espagnol de
laquelle mais a crevé 10 m seulement
après le départ malgré les apparences
christophe moreau a connu plus de
réussite le coureur de l'équipe festina
a terminé meilleur français 4e du
prologue l'espace de quelques minutes il
a même cru pouvoir l'emporter
c'était pas facile à gérer bon j'ai tout
donné on voit là c'est le meilleur temps
c'est c'est formidable et je crois que
c'était vraiment un parcours difficile
où il fallait devrait être très fort
après deux journées mouvementées
richard virenque a enfin pu s'exprimer
sur son vélo le français a logiquement
perdu du temps
les prologues ne lui ont jamais réussi à
l'arrivée il accusait un retard de 50 et
une seconde sur le grand vainqueur du
jour
lane armstrong l'américain atteint la
cancer il y a quelques années est
aujourd'hui revenu au plus haut niveau
en lui minutes et 2 secondes il a
remporté le prologue ici au plus dur est
conquis le premier maillot jaune de sa
vie
le tour cette année veut jouer la
transparence pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de la grande boucle tous les
cyclistes ont subi tout ce matin des
contrôles sanguins et très
officiellement tous ont été déclarés
négatifs l'illégal si olivier julien les
coureurs les appelle les vampires
vampire car ils viennent prendre leur
sang
les contrôleurs de lycées y débarque à
l'hôtel de l'équipe all thy leur visite
est annoncée il est 6 heures ce matin
un peu plus tard richard virenque a fini
sa prise de sang mais il ne le dira pas
un mot pas plus que ses coéquipiers
il faut dire que l'endroit est bien
nommé en tout les 180 partants ont donc
été contrôlé ce matin résultats
officiels aucun hématocrite supérieure à
50% problème quelle est l'utilité d'un
contrôle annoncée quand on sait que les
coureurs peuvent grâce à certains
produits faire baisser leur taux
d'hématocrite
avant la prise de sang lorsque le
contrôle ne fait inopinée c'est vrai
qu'on peut discuter delà de l'intérêt
majeur
de ce contrôle en revendre à ce matin en
revanche les taux d'hématocrite
elles sont jugées entre 47 et 50 parce
que pas même une amélioration par
rapport à lutter face aux suspensions à
50% suspicion à 47%
ce deuxième élément est nouveau mais
suffira-t-il à changer les mentalités
certains coureurs ne le crois pas
beaucoup de croix disais qu'il fallait
que ça change
en fait ils veulent que ça change pour
l'emploi des jeunes dans le problème il
est là et je pense qu'encore dans la
conscience du coureur et de pas mal de
monde
le belgique peut entraîner le dopage
n'est pas n'est pas n'est pas présent
mais personne n'est pas du dopage mais
dieu aux policiers qui pourrait venir
quoi t'en fais un constat bien
inquiétant de la part d'un coureur connu
dans le peloton pour n'avoir jamais pris
de produits dopants et cette question
qui reste combien seront ils avec lui
cette année sur le tour pour défendre
l'avenir du cyclisme le tour de france
qui reprend toutes ses couleurs avec la
présence le long du parcours et au
départ du prologue de ses supporteurs
aficionados ou simples curieux de la
grande boucle
elsa margot eric de l'agneau on
regardait passer le tour en cherchant le
meilleur endroit pour ne rien rater de
l'épreuve
chez les gaborit on aurait bien aimé
regarder le tour à la télé pas de chance
cet après midi il y avait de
l'athlétisme
on est tellement loin ici du tour de
france que employés à l'aide de suite
mais on va y aller vous êtes loin très
loin
vous allez voir je vais vous emmener
d'ailleurs et pour cause monsieur
gaborit est un petit veinard le tour
passe quasiment dans son jardin voilà
ils sont là ils sentent ils sont venus
ils sont tous là
évidemment pour les autres c'est plus
difficile
certains ont dû lutter pour faire leur
trou contre la barrière sous peine
d'avoir de la course une vision un peu
tronquée et vous voyez rien à la cie les
vrais connaisseurs ont su dénicher le
meilleur panorama les vrais fans
préfèrent attendre sur le parcours
le passage de la favori on atteint les 1
12 et 3 3 et les trois que le mien
l'amérique latine et le prétendre aux
mêmes
côté français on aussi plutôt entre
scepticisme et vieilles l'idole
spécialement par ailleurs de gros sujets
préférés en particulier
on aura compris
malgré ces petits soucis de l'an passé
c'est encore richard virenque qui
déchaîne l'enthousiasmé à lui maintenant
de ne pas décevoir ses fans et de
continuer tout au long de la grande
boucle a star avait la foule
mais en direct du puy du fou
florent gautreau après les soubresauts
de ces dernières semaines quelle était
l'ambiance aujourd'hui dans le peloton
bien l'ambiance est parfois encore un
peu pesant de ce tour 99 nous rappellent
par ce côté là le tour 98 certains
directeurs sportifs hésitent à répondre
à la presse et la plupart des coureurs
engagés ne veulent répondre qu'aux
questions qui concernent la course elle
même et pas à celles concernant les
affaires de dopage mais au fur et à
mesure de la journée
l'atmosphère est devenue moins tendue
quand les coureurs ont appris que les
résultats des contrôles sanguins et bien
étaient tous négatifs tous les coureurs
ont pu prendre le départ du prologue un
prologue on l'a vu a remporté par
l'américain lance armstrong sa moyenne
horaire intéressante 50 km/heure
sensiblement la même moyenne que celles
réalisées il y a 6 ans ici même sur ce
parcours du puy du fou par miguel
indurain c'est vrai que ces contrôles
sanguins avaient un petit peu gâché
l'ambiance et c'était aussi un signe de
transparence vous l'avez dit du côté du
tour de france maintenant on a
l'impression que ce tour 99 est bel et
bien lancée alors qu'on la dit longtemps
menacée et demain première étape pour
les 180 coureurs première étape entre
montaigu et chalon merci florent
gautreau
ce matin elle la vallée du d'évoluer
rendait un dernier hommage à ces
victimes c'est toute la montagne qui
pleurent aura pu dire le maire de ce
village qui vit son chagrin dans la
discrétion et la pudeur d'idées guyot
thierry meunier
10h ce matin à saint-etienne dans des
volumes plus de 500 personnes sont
rassemblées en silence tout autour de
l'église
ils sont venus pour accompagner une
dernière fois les trois jeunes hommes du
village
les trois enfants du pays tué dans la
catastrophe
pour lui c'est la famille borlée est
trop chère que la lumière ils sont tous
là émotion du maire de saint-etienne
tout comme l'ensemble de ses concitoyens
les trois victimes étaient trois
moniteurs de ski aimé apprécié leurs
collègues moniteurs ont tenu à apporter
leur cercueil avec confiance
avec affection mais quand tu auras tu
notre pèse la gorge serrée le maire
tiendra à leur rendre un ultime hommage
je suis incapable d'analyser toujours
rose mais plus le regard qui nous rend
tout jamais un vide dans notre village
l'homélie sera tout en pudeur tout en
discrétion face à la douleur les mots
paraissent bien dérisoires
ce matin c'est toute la famille de la
montagne qui s'étaient donné rendez vous
une famille unie qui cherche maintenant
à comprendre pourquoi un tel drame a pu
se produire
l'ancien préfet de corse bernard bonnet
libéré sous contrôle judiciaire
promettait hier à sa sortie de prison de
nouvelles révélations
aujourd'hui il s'exprime dans les
colonnes de notre confrère du monde et
affirme que certaines personnes à paris
devront répondre de faits précis
voyons maintenant comment la corse a
réagi aux déclarations de bernard bonnet
sur place olivier théron et diane
richards en prenant leur quotidien les
corses ont pu découvrir leur ancien
préfet bernard bonnet en train de boire
une bière dans un café mais ce n'est pas
tellement sa libération qui appuient un
excédés certains ce seraient plutôt ses
déclarations fracassantes pour les
protagonistes du dossier le passage à
l'offensive
la mise en cause du fonctionnement de la
justice par le préfet bonnet ce serait
une tactique aquatiques en réalité
monsieur bonnet adopte la tactique du
puch celle qui consiste à lâcher de
lancre faut mieux masquer sa fuite
et le but recherché tout simplement
d'obtenir et sans s'en rendre compte en
prenant connaissance des déclarations de
son avocat
un dépaysement de la faire le
dépaysement signifierait que le dossier
et le procès de bernard bonnet et des
gendarmes se tiendrait ailleurs sur le
continent
et ça les corses ne le veulent pas en
revanche les avocats des parties civiles
se disent prêts à entendre toutes les
révélations du préfet y compris les plus
gênantes
il renvoie le problème vers l'état comme
il l'avait fait une première fois avant
d'être entendu a pris une sorte de
langage codé dans lequel il dit à l'état
quelque chose que ne peuvent percevoir
les dire l ensemble de la population il
ya donc un langage a doublé de la double
de vitesse entre bernard bonnet et les
corps constitués dont on attend beaucoup
nous sommes preneurs de cette fameuse
vérité de ceux de ce qu'il doit révéler
de ses grandes révélations six
révélations et diam je suis un petit peu
circonspect du côté du palais de justice
d'ajaccio on ne commente pas les
accusations de complot judiciaire corse
lancé par bernard bonnet le juge
d'instruction patrice cambérou et le
procureur jacques dallest sts les écarte
d'un revers de code de procédure pénale
il on distille respecter le droit et
seulement le droit et pour sa part jean
pierre chevènement ministre de
l'intérieur a réagi désir soir indiquant
que l'ancien préfet s'est livré une
polémique inacceptable je vous proposais
l'écouté je suis heureux qu'il a
retrouvé la liberté
j'ai défendu la présomption d'innocence
elle est naturellement le préfet bonnet
a le droit de se défendre mais il ne
peut pas oublier qu'il reste préfet de
la république et il ne veut pas se
livrer à des polémiques inacceptable
c'est donc bernard kouchner qui aura la
difficile mission de réinstaller la paix
au kosovo nommé hier administrateur
provisoire de la province par le
secrétaire général de l'onu
le médecin français militant engagé des
droits de l'homme a été choisi par kofi
annan pour sa combativité son
enthousiasme le chef de l'ue ces cas là
aussitôt assuré de son soutien dans
cette période éminemment délicate où le
risque d'affrontements entre communautés
et croissants bernard kouchner aura à
ses côtés plusieurs adjoints chargés
d'administrer le kosovo eric monnet je
cherchais quelqu'un qui te lis des
gestionnaires ou quelqu'un qui a une
vision quelqu'un qui connaît les
terrains qui à la fois à l'aise à à
paris et soul et cali ou bien il est cet
homme
c'est bernard kouchner nommé hier par le
secrétaire général de l'onu kofi annan
haut représentant des nations unies au
kosovo
un choix longue à se dessiner les états
unis n'étaient pas prêts à abandonner la
responsabilité de l'après guerre c'est à
n'importe qui le docteur kouchner sera
donc secondes et dans sa mission par un
américain cette mission c'est d'abord de
réinstaller les réfugiés kosovars qui
rentrent en masse depuis quelques jours
beaucoup ont perdu leurs maisons
détruites dans les bombardements de
l'otan ou incendiés par les militaires
et miliciens serbes une reconstruction
qui coûtera cher bernard kouchner et
calmes déjà autant d'argent pour la paix
au kosovo que pour la guerre il faut non
seulement reconstruire mais construire
l'administration moi je connais le
kosovo j'y suis allé plusieurs fois
l'administration était aux mains des
serge souhaite bien sûr qu'il revienne
mais en attendant il faut que cette
administration fonctionne c'est l'autre
priorité du nouveau haut représentant
une tâche périlleuse que faire de la
minorité serbe encore dans la province
quelle attitude opposée à la puissance
de l'eau checa l'armée de libération du
kosovo
c'est un autre français qui devrait aux
côtés de bernard kouchner être chargée
de ce difficile dossier le préfet
dominique vian enfin il faudra bien un
jour organiser des élections on est loin
d'en être là aujourd'hui à pristina pour
bernard kouchner
la reconstruction et la réconciliation
au kosovo prend
au moins dix ans et la tension apprécié
au nez avec ces manifestations marquant
le neuvième anniversaire de la
déclaration d'indépendance par le
gouvernement du kosovo
deux civils ont été tués et deux autres
ont été blessés par les soldats
britanniques la nuit dernière
les militaires auraient agi en état de
légitime défense face à ces manifestants
circulant à bord d'une voiture qui
aurait ouvert le feu
reste que selon un témoin les passagers
de la voiture n'ont fait que tirer en
l'air et puis des dizaines de milliers
de personnes de la communauté albanaise
étaient descendus dans les rues hier
soir cette manifestation précisément des
albanais a suscité de nouvelles
inquiétudes dans la communauté serbe
provoquant de nouveaux départs ces jours
ci ils sont des milliers à fuir par peur
de représailles
l'exemple de ce village à l'est de
christina entièrement composée de serbes
comme il en existe encore quelques-uns
au kosovo ici comme ailleurs c'est la
peur qui prévaut bertrand cocq dominique
bonnet c'est un village serbe
exclusivement gratsch annica sur la
route de guily année 2500 habitants
les serbes de granit ça sont des paysans
des petits fonctionnaires des gens
modestes qui vivent là depuis toujours à
l'abri de leur monastère l'un des lieux
saints de la mémoire serbes au kosovo
mes grands parents mes arrière grands
parents et leurs parents sont enterrés
là derrière l'église
c'est pas vrai et sous la même croix il
ya ma place et celle de mes enfants
devant l'église il ya un bistrot
le 13 189 date de la bataille du champ
des merles perdu par les serbes face aux
ottomans les serbes d'aujourd'hui n'ont
pas l'air plus vainqueur la peur
s'accroche à eux comme une épidémie leur
monde s'écroule on les traite de petit
blanc ils se vivent comme des assiégés
en subissons deux occupations celle des
albanais et celle de la kfor nous avons
vécu cinq cents ans sous domination
turque ihh maria nous avions perdu
militairement mais un jour ils sont
rentrés chez eux et nous nous sommes
restés pourquoi voulez vous que nous
soyons coupable le peuple n'est pas
responsable des élus arrivent à ce qu
était le coupable alors nous savons tous
qui sait il n'est pas si il était
assistant à la fac de médecine à
pristina ils ont perdu leur travail
comme radovan victimes de la des
services à sion du secteur public
entreprises par les albanais radovan lui
travaillait dans un garage d'état depuis
15 ans en somalie
ils nous ont viré le tchèque l'autre
jour ils sont venus là où je travaillais
et ils nous ont flanqué dehors ils nous
ont dit dégagé votre place n'est plus
ici
radovan dit aussi qu'ils ne se voient
pas d'avenir
tout ce que j'ai fait dans ma vie est
ici dit il
je ne veux pas le perdre mais je sais
que je ne peux pas rester non plus je
sais pas quoi faire
radovan a ouvert son propre atelier
il a le rire crâne pour ses visiteurs
mais le coeur n'y est pas son départ
comme celui des autres servent de granit
ça serait l'échec de la communauté des
nations qui décide à présent de l'avenir
du kosovo en irlande du nord à la veille
de la marche des orangistes sept marches
protestantes organisées chaque année
dans la petite ville de porta donne à un
dispositif de sécurité renforcé se met
en place avec l'arrivée d'un bataillon
militaire composée de 400 hommes en tout
1000 300 soldats supplémentaires ont été
envoyés dans la province pour les
manifestations à venir tout faire pour
éviter la confrontation dans cette
petite ville au sud ouest de belfast qui
est l'un des bastions des opposants à
l'accord de paix qui a tant de mal à
voir le jour
le président égyptien en visite à paris
a été reçu à l'elysée après un déjeuner
avec jacques chirac les deux hommes ont
tenu à marquer leur optimisme concernant
la relance du processus de paix au
proche orient
et puis par ailleurs le président de la
république a indiqué qu'il espérait bien
aller en algérie
ce sera pour moi une joie les
circonstances ne s'y sont pas encore
prêté mais jacques chirac envisager d'y
aller le plus tôt possible
fin de citation à dourdan près de paris
se tenait aujourd'hui la convention
nationale de sos racisme qui vient de
changer de président c'est malek boutih
qui prend la tête du mouvement avec l
intention de lutter contre la violence
dans les cités et les trafiquants de
drogue jean michel carpentier lors de
nadaillac 15 ans déjà la petite main
touche pas à mon pote n'a pas disparu
mais les temps et les discours ont
changé
sos racisme luttent toujours contre la
violence dans les cités et en priorité
celles des trafiquants de drogue qui
font régner la terreur dans les
quartiers
petit à petit on est en train d'en
fermer ses quartiers dans des vrais des
toiles américaine ou ceux qui font la
loi ce sont les caïds ce sont les plus
violents c'est la loi du plus fort qui
est en train de s'imposer
concrètement vous seriez prêt à accuser
un certain nombre de maires d'élus
locaux de connivence avec les dealers
avec le monde de la drogue parce que ça
assure le calme dans les quartiers
oui je crois qu'il ya une partie des
élus qui aujourd'hui s'adresse plus aux
chefs de bande co responsables
associatifs vous comprenez le chef de
bande
vous faites un petit accord avec lui
vous le laissez faire et on est
tranquille le responsable associatif
il vient il dérange y pose des questions
il a des revendications alors on laisse
faire et puis on pense que tout va
rester dans le calme sauf que les chefs
de bande ils maîtrisent rien du tout et
un jour ou l'autre tout ça va exploser
le langage et le même devant les jeunes
est ce que finalement la violence
n'appelle pas la violence et la violence
portées par les jeunes n'étaient elles
pas plus excusable que la violence que
la société elle porte quand ces jeunes
cette violence elle il n'y a rien à
attendre je pense vraiment que tous ceux
qui ont abandonné ou un autre été amenés
à considérer avec un peu de sympathie
moi je n'ai aucune sympathie contre les
caries contre les dealers et je leur
déclare la guerre
et d'ailleurs ce n'est pas un hasard si
en général c'est ma que c'est ces
dealers s'en prennent tout de suite aux
travailleurs sociaux
tout de suite ils s'en prennent dès que
nous essayons de faire quelque chose il
essaye d'organiser la casse pour vous
empêcher d'être présent sur le terrain
ils ont compris que leurs pires
adversaires
c'était nous c'est and policy le spoiler
n'aime pas les forces de répression
quinze ans après la petite main
antiraciste a décidé de lutter encore et
toujours contre la drogue cette fois
vous souvenez peut-être de ce courtier
anglais responsable de la faillite de la
banque britannique barings ce golden boy
condamné à singapour en 95 a été libéré
plus tôt que prévu pour bonne conduite
comme nous le raconte luc bastien quatre
ans et quatre mois plus tard passés en
prison nick leeson ressort libre
toujours souriant mais moins triomphant
son image est devenu une légende
bonne ou mauvaise en fonction de qui le
jugent ces d'ici à singapour que nick
leeson a fait trembler puis finalement
tombée en faillite la plus vieille
banque d'affaires britannique barings
après une cavale il est finalement
arrêté en mars 95 à francfort puis
condamné à 6 ans et 6 mois de prison
pour escroquerie lors de transactions
douteuses sur les marchés dérivés
asiatiques depuis derrière les barreaux
de cette prison de singapour nick leeson
a gardé le sens des affaires
il a d'abord écrit ses mémoires
intitulées courtier sans scrupules et
aurait touché pour sa 4 millions et demi
de francs inspiré de son livre un film
vient de sortir en angleterre et son
avocat bien réel celui-là ça ne
s'invente pas s'appelle m polar
une histoire policière et financière qui
fait vendre même ici au harry's bar de
singapour ou t-shirts et bières sont à
l'image de nick leeson selon la presse
britannique friande de ce genre
d'histoire nick leeson conseiller ses co
détenus pour leurs placements financiers
étonné même les comptes de l'atelier de
couture pour seulement 15 francs par
jour
cet ancien compagnon de cellule affirme
lui que nick leeson aurait caché 18
millions de francs mais le polar se
finit mal
nick leeson a été opéré d'un cancer du
côlon en août dernier et la justice
britannique vient de jeu laissait bien
financièrement
il ne pourra donc plus voler de ses
propres ailes autres en france avec la
route des départs en vacances une
journée classée orange par bison futé
qui a été plutôt calme malgré en fin de
matinée plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres
de bouchons notamment dans la vallée du
rhône
cette année les gendarmes ont mis en
place un dispositif particulièrement
voyants pour garantir la sécurité
routière david base et marie pierre
cassignard un grand jour de départ près
de bordeaux des dizaines de milliers de
véhicules et 500 gendarmes là pour être
vus mission la dissuasion les présence
visible des usagers un bordereau dax et
et recherche impression deux infractions
génératrices d'accidents surtout sur une
journée le grand départ ledy sa sécurité
non port de ceinture en sécurité
l'usager qui téléphonent en conduisant
ces infractions n'ont pas de contrôle
radar les automobilistes verbalisés
aujourd'hui l'ont été pour non port de
la ceinture ou pour véhicules surchargés
mais ces gendarmes omniprésent ne
peuvent rien contre l' imprudence
circulation continue sans à-coups
d'accord l'actualité ressemble une fois
de plus aux images chocs des spots de
prévention routière bilan quelques
blessés légers missions de secours pour
les gendarmes paroles amères beaucoup de
gendarmes ce matin pourtant sur le
terrain
et voilà les c'est surtout les distances
il ya des panneaux de signalisation
partout qu'il rappelle qu'il faut
respecter la vitesse qu'il faut
respecter les distances sur l'autoroute
mais globalement cette journée n'a pas
été le point noir attendu de la
circulation et de la sécurité routière
il semble que les usagers aient respecté
un petit peu les règles qu'ils auront
eux demander d'étaler les vacances il
n'y a pas eu le fonds de départ comme en
connaissions habituellement de juillet à
fin août les gendarmes vont rester sur
le pied de guerre
l'an dernier il y a eu 25 morts par jour
sur les routes de l'été et pour ceux qui
prennent donc la route aujourd'hui
prudence prudence au volant ce matin un
accident entre un autocar tchèque et une
caravane a fait un mort et 21 blessés
dont plusieurs grièvement
le plan rouge a été déclenché près de
narbonne
je vous propose maintenant ce reportage
sur une des aires de repos installés sur
les autoroutes françaises des dizaines
de personnes y travaillent
une entreprise qui génère des millions
de francs sur ces aires de repos étape
obligée de la route des vacances
l'ambiance à beaune où se côtoient
touristes et employés reportage ces
panneaux mans julien trias bienvenue sur
l'air de beaune-tailly un petit village
d'une centaine d'habitants qui accueille
vingt mille visiteurs les jours de
grands départs
son forum central sa poste son musée
archéologique sa piscine improvisée son
complexe de loisirs et son aire de pique
nique pour les étrangers tout le charme
bucolique des petites routes de france
c'est vraiment très jolie c'est ce que
nous avons vu de plus jolis depuis que
nous sommes arrivés en france on est
parti ce matin à 4 heures 4 heures du
matin et on a roulé 12 heures depuis la
hollande pose en moyenne une demi-heure
le plus souvent à la demande des enfants
les enfants clients choyer un industriel
distribuer ici gratuitement des petits
pots car ce village et surtout une bonne
affaire commerciale boutiques cafés et
restaurants hôtels toutes catégories une
aire de repos fait travailler des
dizaines de salariés et génère les
bénéfices d'une grosse entreprise ce qui
regarde passer les vacanciers de l'anrt
tiennent pas rigueur
le poids du non absolument pas
absolument pas
retour ce sera quand la famille harper
15 ou une fois que ça commence à
insulter ou septembre de manière aussi
il y aura plus de place à beaune tailly
petit village du bord des vacances
personne n'est dupe
le soleil du vrai repos est encore loin
il arrivait des premiers vacanciers près
de la rochelle par exemple à
châtelaillon cette journée des
juillettistes dans un camping on re
découvre les plaisirs de la plage et de
la baignade malgré un temps mitigé
christophe devals embrasse alain néri
grands ils ont bravé l'autoroute un jour
de grand départ en colonnes par deux
pendant des heures et puis les premiers
ont touché au but les vacances des
juillettistes peuvent commencer
on retrouve les amis de l'an dernier on
retrouve aussi les ennuis de l'an
dernier c'est le début des vacances n'a
alors bon il ya des pièces en rab et
chaque année c'est le même problème
heureusement les copains sont là pour
donner un coup de main des syndiqués la
perte est alors rapidement le camp est
monté et chacun retrouve ses réflexes
d'été balade à vélo pour digérer petit
café tranquille à l'ombre des pins pêche
à la ligne pourquoi pas tout le monde
trouve son bonheur
y compris ceux qui travaillent dur
saison au niveau travail s'annonce mais
enfin la satisfaction de
d'avoir un taux de remplissage parfait
et puis essayer de rendre les gens
heureux les déstresser
le patron du camping a le moral le
patron du restaurant de plage aussi
enfin les clients sont là cette attaque
les premiers vacanciers arrivent
monsieur eh bien je pense me en fait
malgré le temps incertain je pense que
ça arrive la saison red bull alors la
rencontre après c'est bien parti
je pensais en tout cas les premiers
juillettistes n'ont pas perdu une
seconde à peine arrivé aujourd'hui
premier jour club de plage pour les
enfants et pour les parents première
séance de fargniers certains malgré la
marée basse se serait même offert leur
première bnia la porte de versailles à
paris le rendez vous des philatélistes
avec ce salon mondial qui réunit les
plus belles collections l'occasion pour
gilles and bar et alexis delcourt de
retracer l'histoire de la vie d'un
timbre non nous ne sommes pas au mondial
de l'automobile
mais au mondial du timbre
transportons-nous dans son histoire en
commençant par la raison de sa naissance
le timbre la taxe était payé par le
destinataire mais que les anglais ont
constaté que par des messages codés qui
étaient inscrits sur les surfaces des
plis les destinataires refusé parce
qu'ils avaient obtenu leurs messages
sans payer ils ont préféré ils ont
souhaité transformer donc la loi et
obliger les gens à payer au départ avec
un timbre et c'est l'origine de la
création du tableau
nous étions alors en 1840 en grande
bretagne la france elle crée son premier
timbre en 1849 à l'éffigie de crs une
déesse romaine des moissons au fait
comment crée-t-on atteindre en france
ils sont tous fabriqués à périgueux par
la poste sur ce genre d'appareil cette
machine date de 1930 un poinçon
cylindrique tourner sur une bande de
papier humidifié avec de lancre saint
prime
le dessin voulu ensuite il est découpé
laventure du timbre commence alors
puisque par nature il est appelé à
voyager en 1849 le transport du courrier
était assurée essentiellement par route
puis par mer mais une lettre n'était 12
jours pour traverser l'atlantique
le transport postal a pris son essor
dans les airs avec d'abord la
montgolfière en 1870 et c'est avec cet
avion que le premier vol postal
officielle a lieu en 1913 puis ce fut
une aventure de l'aéropostale
une fois arrivé à destination commence
une seconde vie pour le teindre la
collection il prend de la valeur en
fonction de sa rareté et de son état de
conservation
je n'aime pas des timbres qui manque de
temps ou se sont plaît je sais comment
c'est à 8 ans
quand j'ai découvert le marché au timbre
à paris que j'aime particulièrement sur
les chats des collections originales que
même les plus jeunes de la génération de
l'e-mail pourront admirer jusqu'au 11
juillet l'été des festivals avec cette
manifestation itinérante qui se déroule
sur le canal du midi ou plus précisément
sur une péniche spectacle un voyage qui
s'achèvera à la fin du mois 7 jean
jacques duffau blaise grenier on est
dans la jungle
la jeune fille faisait festival au fil
de l'eau le long des canaux le bateau
bastian you 5 5 6 kilomètres heure mais
là beaucoup moins
allez pas passé on n'est pas du genre c
'est pas spectacle histoires capitaine
du fenniche longtemps à marc et jean
marie en avait assez d'être hacké envie
de bouger et il a décidé de voyager
vider des festivals c'est bien ça quand
c'est de prolonger les activités d'un
lieu culturel qu'est la péniche sur le
canal du midi est donc de faire
appliquer le bateau est de faire
finalement vivre le canal d'un drap sa
plénitude
un plus pour le canal est une aubaine
pour les riverains puisque ce festival
itinérant et charmant ne nécessite pas
de dépenser d'argent
le spectacle est gratuit il suffit que
la péniche à marcq pour que la fête
démarre on navigue dans la cale du
bateau on a tout le matériel
la sonorisation les artistes nous
rejoignent où navigue avec nous est
arrivé sur le site d'un an des charges
et en espagne on plante le décor
mais la tâche reste
non
ce soir là sur les berges du canal il y
avait bernardo sandoval bernardo hees à
musiques métisses mélangeant les eaux de
la méditerranée et celle de l'atlantique
parfois dures parfois temps tout va bien
de l'amour et parce qu'il est après il
ya des fois j'avais l'intention de me
gaver quoi vous mettez chiffres brillait
des fois les gens réservent un jour
dans la tradition des baladins et des
mariniers convives annecy est un
festival de planeurs de voyageurs c'est
l'ouverture à l'autre à sa musique à sa
culture ses rencontres et l'autre et
pour ce que proposent le voyage
d'ailleurs quand on voyage et dans cette
ambiance dance mêmes contredanses on a
tout le temps de perdre état de
rencontres piano au fil de l'eau la
dernière exposition au centre pompidou
avant sa réouverture totale le 1er
janvier 2000 exposition consacrée au
peintre français robert delaunay et fut
l'un des pionniers de l'abstraction
l'exposition retrace les années
précédant la première guerre mondiale
ces années où tout a basculé antoine
cormery claude barnier au début du
siècle
robert delaunay tour eiffel c'est comme
ça qu'il la voyait
tordu désarticulé brisé entre 1909 et
1911 il lui a fait subir les pires
outrages
foin de géométrie et de lignes de fuite
robert delaunay se refuse à choisir la
meilleure perspective
alors comme les cubistes il les
représente tout simultanément
né en 1885 il avait pourtant commencé de
manière classique en emboîtant le pas
aux impressionnistes au pointilliste et
aux fauves dont les couleurs claquent si
magnifiquement la couleur justement il
en faire le coeur de son oeuvre c'est
elle qui va le conduire à l'abstraction
la plus radicale
en moins de 8 ans et en rupture avec la
peinture telle qu'on la pratiquait
depuis la renaissance il va avoir toutes
les audaces tous les culots avant moi
disait-il par provocation les autres
n'avaient fait que du coloriage alors
que la couleur doit se suffire à elle
même
ce credo basée sur de très sérieuses
théories scientifiques menées au 19ème
nouveau aujourd'hui d'admirer ses
tableaux rayonnant l'exposition qui
couvre la période la plus féconde de sa
carrière met ainsi en évidence son rôle
de précurseur bien avant les grands
peintres abstraits américains
le grand disque de 1913 frappé sur la
façade de beaubourg témoigne de cette
modernité sport du basket avec la
défaite de la france devant l'équipe et
yougoslaves qui remporte la médaille de
bronze de l'euro 99 74 à 62 et puis du
tennis à wimbledon pete sampras numéro
un mondiale l'a battu en quatre sets
le britannique tim henman andré agassi a
lui aussi gagné contre l'australien à
patrick rafter c'est donc une finale
agassi sampras qui se déroulera demain
pour ses internationaux c'est la fin de
ce journal je vous appelle les
principaux titres le départ du tour de
france avec le prologue au puy du fou
c'est l'américain lance armstrong qui
prend le maillot jaune le premier
maillot jaune il 180 coureurs ont tous
subi les contrôles sanguins ce matin une
première dans l'histoire de la grande
boucle le chagrin de la vallée du
dévoluy qui rendait un dernier hommage
ce matin à trois de ses victimes la
pudeur et le recueillement dans un
instant l'avenue météo nathalie rihouet
20h50 fort boyard
0 heure trente le dernier journal elle
mettait à 12h02 mal l'émission géopolis
de claude sérillon
je vous retrouve dès 13 heures je vous
remercie de votre attention excellente
soirée sur france 2
vim